[Music]
hello again time then for the press
preview it's our first look at what is
on tomorrow's front pages so we're going
to check out the headlines tonight with
the political editors of the daily
mirror and the sun pepper carrera and
harry cole i'm sure they've got a few
things to say they'll be with us from
now until just before midnight speak to
you both in a second let's check out
those front pages first for you though
the metro leads with the publication of
photos apparently showing the prime
minister giving a toast at an event that
broke lockdown rules in november 2020
and the guardian is also leading with
the picture showing boris johnson having
a drink at number 10.
the telegraph leads with the pictures
too and says scotland yard is coming
under pressure for not fining boris
johnson for attending the event
the ft says that rishi sunak is drawing
up new plans for a possible windfall tax
to tackle the rising cost of living
the mail leads with planned rail strikes
which it says could cause power outages
and supermarkets to run low on food
supplies
and the sun has a report that one of the
pitch invaders at the etihad stadium has
been found to be an off-duty police
officer
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen join the
program you can check out the front
pages of tuesday's papers while you
watch and listen to us and i'm joined
tonight by pippa carrera and harry cole
great to see you both this monday
evening um pippa why don't you kick
things off for us front page of the
guardian their headline fresh danger for
johnson over number 10 drinks pictures
more pictures
have been released itv getting hold of
these ones and this photograph
this series of photographs pippa really
prompting more questions about whether
the prime minister misled parliament
that's right and it's been interesting
the last couple of days as we sit here
waiting for sue gray's report which
we're expecting uh possibly tomorrow or
um wednesday
um a lot of debate about the photos and
uh whether or not she would include
some of the 300 photos which she handed
over to police for the police for their
investigation
um and the suggestion seems to be that
tonight that that she will indeed
include some of those events number 10
response throughout this has been that
they are relaxed and very happy like the
fact that photos might be forthcoming
because some in number 10 believe that
the public imagination has kind of got
carried away and the public expect to
find you'd see pictures of the prime
minister swinging from the chandeliers
or you know
aids surrounded by piles and piles of
empty bottles whereas in fact the
pictures are much more of the the ilk
the one that was released today by itv
uh smaller groups of people in this case
um i think an eight are in short but
there's more behind the scenes um uh
standing around in what is obviously
work environment drinking the problem is
is that standing around in a work
environment and drinking it what clearly
is a social gapping there is the prime
minister raises a toast to his departing
spin doctor lee kane was against the
rules at the time which said of course
that um two
uh that you weren't allowed to meet
anybody from another household indoors
and the the thing which is um angering
many junior officials and indeed some
senior ones in number 10 tonight is that
fines
uh were uh were given out by the police
for that event and others that the prime
minister was in attendance at but he of
course was not fine so the big question
on the front of the globe on the
telegraph and other newspapers tonight
is why was the prime minister not fined
when they were what is this sort of the
exemption that the police are relying on
um to to decided not to find him and uh
you know there's certainly lots of
questions for them and number 10 to
answer uh we'll probably have to wait
until the secret report comes out more
yeah exactly and of course the lib dems
and others calling on the police
watchdog to to investigate that very
question um harry looking inside your
paper the sun hangover two uh is the
headline and what they actually do what
your paper does is sort of goes into
detail about what is on the table here
as boris johnson is raising his glass uh
two bottles of fizz four bottles of wine
one bottle of gin i mean it it it looks
like a party doesn't it and if some were
fined at this event uh it was clearly
illegal so um so it's it's a very fair
question why why didn't the prime
minister get a get a fine for it
well i think he's he's used what's
commonly going to become known as the
kia's diamond offense that he went back
to work afterwards he may have broken
off from work had a drink raised a glass
the defense i think they're going to
wriggle on and they're going to try and
use is this idea that was reasonably
necessary for work
the
allies of mr johnson tonight saying look
he it was a fraught time in downing
street that just been one hell of a um
sort of internal power struggle a battle
he stopped on his way back to the double
ten flat red box in hand had a drink
whether that stands next to scrutiny i'm
not sure because there are people in
that room that say no actually the prime
minister was the one pouring the glasses
and instigating the chat so it's gonna
be a rough old week for for mr johnson
because the first time we ever saw
actually the stark image
of a lockdown event was always gonna be
a tricky time whether that came in sue
grey's report or not as i mentioned
there was some debate about whether they
were going to publish the pictures it
seems to me like someone on the outside
won't take a million guesses to work out
who is trying to pressure sue gray to
include those photographs by publishing
or leaking this one tonight yeah so do
you think harry um just very quickly
that means that that the the report may
be delayed further then
i don't know i think there's everyone's
pretty keen to get out the door now sue
gray i suspect wants to get on with her
job of running the the leveling up
department and downing street aren't we
wanting to hold this up any longer yeah
people up front of the daily telegraph
um uh discussing what we were saying a
moment ago pressure on met over pictures
of the prime minister raising a toast in
number 10. i mean
it's hard to know how this changes
things doesn't it um the public um uh
rightly
could well be very furious about it but
in terms of tory mps
i'm not getting the sense that it's
going to change how they feel about the
prime minister at the moment is is that
your understanding from from what you're
hearing from sources
yes that's right i mean there's been a
two there's been a couple of examples of
mps that's already called the premise
just to go and then u-turned or held off
saying that now actually um it's time
for him uh
that he that he should go but
we're still in a position that we were
this time a week ago this time a month
ago where um the majority of
conservative backbenchers are not
calling for the prime minister to go and
not sacking him as it were but they're
definitely not backing him either and i
think their silence is notable tonight
very few um tory mps are coming out and
being vocal about why he should survive
beyond a few of his closest allies um so
i think there's a sort of a feeling that
they need they want to wait and see what
the sugar reports contents uh reveal but
it doesn't seem to me and it hasn't
seemed to me for some time as though the
mps this is going to be
anything which the mps are going to to
try and announce the pm over i mean not
since february when there was that pork
pie plot and um you know tensions were
heightening the public anger was
escalating now people have kind of
accepted that this is what's happened i
think um the public had made their minds
up some time ago that they feel the
prime minister lied whether he received
one fine or multiple fines they'd come
to their own conclusions the damage for
the prime minister i think is done in
terms of his reputation particularly in
some of those blue wall seats in the
south and amongst some of the more
traditional conservative areas where
probability and individual um integrity
uh matters to to voters um very highly
so um
i think that you know the damage is done
i'm not convinced that this could shift
the dial massively but of course we need
to wait and see yeah we do need to wait
and see and of course uh it's not just
um uh partygate and sue gray's report
that is uh uh um taking up a lot of time
in westminster the cost of living crisis
uh also um a major issue this week
financial times has got a story harry
big power generators in sunax sites for
widened windfall tax the windfall tax
debate continues
yeah it looks like the there are some
elements of government i'm not entirely
sure richie stewart himself is backing
this but definitely some elements of the
treasury want to essentially still label
his clothing on this one it's been an
idea that labor have been pushing a
windfall tax on north sea oil and gas
since about i think uh january or
december last year now it seems to me
that they're plotting that they could go
even further and actually look at the
electricity generating companies who
because of the rise in in wholesale
price of electricity
whether they make it out of uh gas or
wind or or tidal whatever i've had a
very very good year as well so we could
see i i'm i think it's one option on the
table we could see quite a sweeping
windfall tax if they can convince the
prime minister and the trade and the and
the chancellor who have on the record
saying this is not a good idea and not
one that conservatives should be doing
that actually there's enough money to be
raised there to hold their nose so to
speak okay all right we'll get your
views on this pippa um a little bit
later on in the programme uh we need to
go to a break coming up including this
story in the sun kabul botch civil
servant must go don't go
[Music]
welcome back part to the press preview
pippa and harry's still with me pippa uh
story here which is interesting isn't it
this is about the foreign office boss
philip barton
and you'll remember he was the man who
stayed on holidays afghanistan fell well
he could be in hot water about it
there's a scathing report out today by
the foreign affairs committee which has
been looking into the withdrawal of
british troops and um
british allies translators and so on
from afghanistan when kabul fell to the
taliban last summer and the focus of
this story uh by harry's colleague kate
is on philip barton it describes him as
a bunk the bundling foreign office chief
he was the the committee the employee
committee did not hold back on the
criticism of him he of course stayed on
holidays for 11 days when kabul fell and
left it to junior officials to to work
the way through um he and other senior
senior officials stayed away so too did
dominic rob the foreign secretary at the
time who was on holiday in crete and um
uh you know you'll remember the sort of
famous wrangling subsequently about
whether the beach was closed he claimed
that he was working there but of course
he wasn't back at the foreign office
where um really leadership was needed
and as the committee of mps has found
today
wasn't wasn't present either on the
official side or the mp site so you know
it's not a failure it's criticism also
of the um the the charity scheme pen
firing scheme to if you remember um
get pets get get dogs out of afghanistan
feeling that they maybe were prioritized
possibly from interests at the top of
government um but over over getting
people out safely there were still
translators and people that supported
the uk stuck
um so you know this is ongoing but very
very scathing and they could quit okay
um harry quick word on that and then i'm
going to ask you about the story on the
front of the sun
yeah no i'm normally quite um
sympathetic of the uh the idea that it
should the buck should stop at the very
top and the minister should be
responsible
having sat through philip barton's
evidence session uh to the committee you
can see why they were so scathing i mean
i remember there being absolute you know
jaws on the floor uh and some of the
answers he was giving mps and crucially
let's not forget that dominic rob with
the bauble of uh of deputy prime
minister was essentially demoted from
the foreign office in the wake of this
uh
make of this uh what was it call it what
it is scandal yeah okay um we'll leave
that there we're running out of time but
i just want to look at the front of the
sun um
talking about that pitch invasion i mean
the number of pitch invasions haven't
there um in recent days but uh
this is quite a headline some pcs are on
the pitch
yeah but this wasn't this weekend but a
previous event whether the police have
now been trawling through the cctv and
were shocked to discover one of their
own uh on the pitch i really feel that
this is a you know at a time when we're
talking about liberalizing rules in
football stadiums perhaps bringing beer
back on uh into into the stands perhaps
having standing again um it seems that
the police the fa the the football
associations are unable to get a grip on
this growing phenomenon of not just
pitch invasions
which are one thing celebrating but
violet the sort of footballers in what
is essentially their place of work and
you know no one wants to see a return to
fences and and the horrors of the past
but something needs to be done very
quickly on this and
i'll our leader tomorrow now columnists
are all recommending hefty hefty fines
for people caught doing this to nip it
in the bud